here's a fun fact did you know that if
you search my online pseudonym charlie
is so cool like on Google Images the
first picture that comes up is of a
watermelon with a face carved into it
this everybody is what Google thinks is
the most accurate visual representation
of me just for comparison that's what
that looks like and that's what I look
like is a prime example I think of just
one of the instances in which the
Internet is a bit weird and that is our
topic for today everybody instances in
which the Internet is a bit weird in
relation to me some time ago on one of
my many egocentric travels across the
Internet I discovered a website called
tumblr and there's a lot of weird stuff
about me on tumblr I'll leave you to
learn more about tumble yourself if
you're not already aware but basically
for our purposes it's a website where
people share pictures with their friends
and for reasons that are probably going
to remain forever beyond me sometimes
people on tumblr like to post pictures
of me usually animated gifs and it's bit
weird this is what I would look like if
I was a dancing badger I don't know what
I'm doing here but that is something
that is on the Internet of me Here I am
in a bathroom this is one of the more
sexy ones I assume this is me trying to
escape from some wrapping paper but
someone's turned it into a little dance
I yeah I think it's called the present
shuffle this is me repeatedly popping up
I I don't I don't know this is
definitely one of the weirdest ones I
just don't I don't understand it I don't
know why somebody did why did you do
this whoever did this why did you do it
this is me jumping up and down in my
pants yeah now my suspicions tell me
that I only find this kind of stuff
weird because it's about me anyone else
is probably just like it's fine they
take pictures of you they like you get
over it but there's other stuff on the
internet about me which I think anybody
would probably find weird so that's what
we're going to cover next for example
did you know that on tumblr there is an
entire blog dedicated specifically just
to shirtless pictures of me it's
probably partly my fault for just
letting there be so many shirtless
images from myself on the internet but
just knowing that there is a place you
can go if you want to see shirtless
pictures of me it's just oh yeah if you
want to see my scrawny body shirtless
Charlie tumblr com hey but it only gets
weirder to the point where it's kind of
uncomfortable to talk about the last
thing I'm
list is cherry mum I have a flatmate
called Alex he's nice he like me makes
YouTube videos under the username
nerimon you might have seen him in a few
episodes of Charlie is so cool like
areas just to refresh your memory you're
right there yep um you're heterosexual
right Alex I am yeah okay yeah I am as
well and if you combine our usernames
charlie is so cool like nerimon you get
this thing called chair imam which it
has a couple of meanings firstly it
pertains to images in which alex and i
have been made to look like Toy Story
characters or in which our faces have
been swapped it's a bit weird sure but
it's harmless but it also refers to a
strange fantasy in which me and my
heterosexual friend are the internet
it's so weird man it's so weird there's
weirdest stuff than just that but I
don't want to talk about the slash
fiction that's just too odd for me Allah
Alex do that awfully the majority of the
images presented in this video apart
from the the really weird ones were
provided by my lovely Twitter followers
so thank you the weirdest picture that
was sent to me was this one from
Fullilove teammate on tumblr so you win
some kind of prize for sending me that I
will be in touch and that's the end of
the video everyone so in conclusion
goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool